des salariés de la sncf son gré vision
aux non grévistes ont reçu une prime
allant de 300 à 1500 euros
voilà donc c'était ce que voulait dire
jean mich est votre meilleur quand ces
gamins balance un dossier qu'il assure
jean-michel et s'attend pas aux menaces
de l'ancien reporter de guerre tu vois
je sais qu'hier soir s'est très bien
passé merci les gars que j'ai des bosses
aussi vois moi bafa calme-toi vraiment
un tricot la chanter moins fort
c'est un à ce calvaire cette fiche parce
qu'ils apportent du regard de jean
michel mr bien sûr en sable c'est très
bien voilà je n'écoute et quand il se
met dehors regardez jean michel il me
donne un coup de pression à son patron
on regarde et on se prend dans un
western
il vous lâche pas sur le genou s'est pas
non plus complètement innocente elle
aimait qu'on le touche et on sortait un
peu lassant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait comment ils voient des signes on
regarde c'est incroyable
[Rires]
ça c'est nous tous
ils sont pourtant importants
une spéciale alors si vous auriez rêvé
d'être en aimant chanteurs comme kenji
peut-être un grand combattant comme van
damme mais aussi on sait tous que vous
auriez voulu être un grand médium comme
codex hirai c'est votre truc
mercredi vous recevez richard anconina
qui venait pour son téléfilm mauvais
garçon qui passait le soir même sur
france 2 a vous dit ça y est vous le
comprenez ce qui va se passer
il faut de plus avait voulu lire dans
vos boules pour pronostiquer l'audience
fait guère de balivernes j'ai pas
pouvoir je crois qu'il va devoir faire
la vidange très bientôt parce qu'il est
temps de plonger dans les boules de baba
tabata fossé
un mauvais garçon c'est ce soir sur
france 2 c'est très très très réussie
ça va et cd audio et moi aussi je pense
qu'on va être en tête des venant ce soir
richard trois mois je le dirai demain et
si c'est le cas il viendrait chez toi
faire une grosse tête alors envie
d'aller chez richard anconina faire la
fête pour ses audiences et vous êtes
tellement sûr de la fiabilité de vos
boules que vous en remettait une couche
vous êtes sûr de votre coup c'est obligé
et se voir le widi il sera en tête des
audiences je le parie voilà je vous le
dis je suis sûr et certain je suis
surtout seront en tête des audiences ce
soir tu va cartonner donc jeudi matin et
coll évidence tombe bien entendu mauvais
garçon sur france 2 est obligatoirement
en tête des audiences plus que vous
l'avait prédit
c'est obligé les noms des files elle est
nue amsterdam sur tf1 qui était en tête
hier soir
on retrouve ensuite france 2 avec
mauvais garçons le téléfilm avec richard
anconina jeu surtout sera en tête des
audiences ce soir tu va cartonner tu sûr
et sain
c'est un cadeau
un carton c'est la marge d'erreur c'est
qu'on délaisse bouleversa mais avait dit
tu verras la mariée ans qui aurait à
voir demain sur tout ce que je veux
faire attention
alors donc tout fait à mon poste on va y
venir les couples se forment et se
déforment maintenant comme dans les
marchés w9 storia des coupes qui se
tendent n'y ait eu un couple qui est en
train de se rapprocher il ya deux
personnes ont ils attendu qui se
rapprocher toutes les images et tous mes
chéris dans un instant vous saurez qui
se rapproche tout cas vu ses deux paires
oui c'est venu vous le dis il ya un
couple qui se forme vous savez le simple
prix monte en moi je suis pas content
non n'avait pas de compte en jours vient
d'après ou pas oui je trouvais un prix
de journée ok on va j'essaie de
m'occuper de combat sont entrés dans un
interview
puisque dans touche pas à mon poste les
couples se forment et se déforment à
volants les marseillais w9 alors ça ce
schisme dans tous les sens même deux
personnes franchement je croyais qu'il
n'avait pas de vie sexuelle non pur
comme geneviève de fontenay qui
commencent à se tourner autour ce soir
je dévoiler au grand jour le petit
manège ces deux personnes qui veulent
nous faire croire que depuis le temps
qu'ils se connaissent il ne s'est rien
passé entre eux quoi à votre avis qui
sont ces deux personnes lors franchement
alors atteinte à temps complet mais
témoigne musique.evous ici
naulleau est-ce que c'est toi banon
non mais lime non bien sûr bonne mère
j'ai le cul propre talent qu propre vélo
fait ni de même talent tu propre le jour
j'ai assez dormir comme ça
[Rires]
tout est propre tout votre bouche si
vous voulez vous moi je ne me faites pas
dire ce que j'ai pas envie de dire
impossible
castaldi à postiches 2 castaldi je veux
dire la vérité je t'aime beaucoup en ce
moment tu es sur la sellette au niveau
de la femme
elle m'envoie énormément des sms ah bon
oui te concernant bout il ya eu
l'épisode sophie cost non non si cela
posé il ya pas d'épisode six épisodes
sophie cost il ya eu l'épisode vient du
crir
ouais où beaucoup de gens parler de toi
si si si si si aujourd'hui à fanning et
chats qu'est ce que tu cherches tu as
inscrit
est ce que tu cherches la peinture
encore de marianne2 pas du tout ça tu
cherches pas du tout pas du tout fanny
bien entendu maryse et fabien mariez
raimondo vraiment moi ça ça ne risque
pas écouté j'ai aussi qu'il s'agit
impossible est ce que quelqu'un a menti
que quelqu'un d'entier aux tonga câble
de cédric une personne a menti une
personne a menti qui sera là dedans si
j'ai dit qu'une personne a menti comme
il faut être deux une personne en train
de dire que la deuxième personne
concernée c'est moi c'est ça que ça
c'est vous elle rigole moins en train de
dire que moi je serai en chine a
enchaîné brand
tiens avec quelqu'un qui se trouve sur
le côté droit n'est pas si il reprocha
que ça ghazi ben écoutez quand le specis
de la merguez rencontre l'aspect c'est
de la boulette des images parlent
d'elles-mêmes malaisie depuis 2012 pour
nous valérie benaïm et cyril hanouna
c'est comme un frère et une soeur mais
c'est vraiment votre soeur cyril nous
avons une famille très bizarre je lui
fais gaffe à 7 sec ce fait gaffe tu as
toujours été ma soeur ton change pas de
famille et parce que depuis quelques
temps à chaque fois que certains
regardent valoches ça frétille dans son
slip aussi froides en 2019 et vous
le coc chaude en 2020 mais non ce n'est
pas un grille pain
ce n'est pas une friteuse et une
bouilloire toi séduire série n'hésite
pas à utiliser son compte et romantique
quand elle est dans le livre on vient
elle tombe elle tourne plus vite les
slips que les pages serrées - semble
tellement amoureux que même quand
valeurs je porte une perruque
dégueulasse il la trouve magnifique
cette coiffure tout va très bien fait et
la vida hymne nous émoustiller avait été
limé mousty c est parce que valence je
commence à craquer à ouvrir son coeur à
baba ça y est et elle m'a appelé c'est
la masse mais il fut dit si je te fasse
ça va déraper
enfin et quand c'est à nous à présent de
l'émission en slip justement valoches ne
peut plus résister au pénal pose est
impressionnant c'est vrai
vous avez la peste et ferme je peux le
cucul chaise comme on voulait ouais
c'est fermé
[Musique]
en question tout le monde se pose c'est
est-ce que valeur j'ai ma ba va enfin
ouvrir la porte de l'amour
[Musique]
effectivement envie d'en parler pour
installer quelque chose n'a pas créé a
dit quelque chose on est copains comme
cochons voilà mais mangent pas de cochon
médaille mais non mais c'est mon frère
lors du dîner ça ne me traverse même pas
du tout ce que vous avez dit jean plus
fort encore 10 minutes de plus un non
non non non mais parce que c'est une
façon d'exprimer une amie l'inspiré
profonde et très sincère et profond
calmez-vous bénin calmez-vous benhalima
et c'est vous êtes toujours être pas
tort huit chefs
est-ce que vous lâche marié patoche pour
moi même temps rêve c'est bien elle
n'est pas une faute d'argent les tester
ma famille et moi depuis que je la
connais mais je sais pas j'étais à la
radio avec ndiaga yade de son chien
content d'avoir 19 ans il a
littéralement donc ça fait vingt ans
plus de 20 ans cent vingt ans que la
connecter jamais mais jamais rien pas
même pas et dieu sait que benhaim en
plus il ya beaucoup d'amis à moi qui
voulais pas choquer ni voilà donc si si
si oui annoncé s'il ya plein de l'avenir
moi qui voulais peu de shopping qui
m'ont dit présentement à beinheim
présentement bénigne c'est vraiment des
personnes quoi la présentation reste
avec patoche
à l'époque quand j'étais disant tech
patoche genoux fléchis fait oui
justement on va finir avec un événement
qui a étonné tous les téléspectateurs la
semaine dernière toutefois mon poste
commence tout public est là tous les
chroniqueurs sont là sauf qu'il manque
une personne
cyril hanouna bon c'est un peu
problématique c'est comme si le concert
de dazhou comment ces sandales jouent
alors heureusement benjamin castaldi il
a improvisé mais je me suis procuré les
images de ce qui vous arrive et pendant
les loges pendant l'émission
une fois que l'émission ait commencé
vous allez voir y a que chez nous qu'on
voit ça encore ici en plus de son
gentiment mais je n'ai pas d'horaires il
est entre l'ici et sa loge
donc je dois commencer l'émission ça
fait deux minutes que touche pas à mon
poste a commencé et l'animateur star de
l'émission celui qui a réinventé la
télévision n'est toujours pas arrivé on
imagine que cyril hanouna et paniquée à
l'idée que l'émission ait commencé sans
lui et donc je suis sûr qu'au même
moment il en train de foncer pour vite
arrivée sur le plateau c'est obligé
[Musique]
les commençants le stress c'est même la
panique de l'animateur de l'émission a
déjà commencé par des comme celle là se
dépêche
alors que pendant ce temps en plateau
deux seigneurs qui jouent au ping pong
avec des poèmes
alors forcément la direction canal+ est
obligé d'intervenir auprès son animateur
avec fermeté regardez-moi ça
ja
celui qui est surnommé l'animal
s'apprête à retourner au monde de son
émission et à propager lanarca dans le
monde entier et surtout stérile a
expliqué la raison de son retard vous
avez tous il ya mes enfants qui sont
venus biancardini exprès pour voir
elie semoun ducobu et tout l'été une
fois de plus pipeau man est de retour
quand vous allez découvrir la raison
pour laquelle cyril hanouna est à rota a
sa propre émission
fred tanneau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]